i'm gonna get this
cue the tears garth brooks had to
compose himself in the middle of his cbs
christmas special on sunday night
yeah the country superstar teamed up
with his wife trisha yearwood for garth
and trish alive
a holiday concert event where viewers
were able to request
songs via social media the couple
treated fans with covers of classics and
originals
but it was his ballad bellow wood that
really got the singer choked up
and before his performance garth
admitted he usually sings an abbreviated
version of it
for that very reason good luck buddy
[Laughter]
cause this one makes me cry and i never
got away we always uh
we always do an abbreviated version of
this if somebody sends a live of signing
live
i don't know how long it's been since
i've played the whole version but if
it's
not too much for you guys i'd like to
play the whole song
i love this whole story i'm going to
kind of step over here because this is
really your song
now for those who don't know garth
co-wrote the song in the 90s about the
1914 christmas truce
cease-fires among british french and
german soldiers
with lyrics highlighting both the
tragedy and triumph of war
then across the frozen battlefield
and others voice joined in
until one by one each man
became a singer of the hymn
[Applause]
i'm gonna get this
[Music]
for right there in my sights
[Music]
a german soldier beneath the falling
flakes of white
but for just one fleeting moment
the answer seemed so clear
that heaven's not beyond the clouds
it's just beyond the feet
[Music]
no heavens not beyond clouds
it's for us to find it
here
almost made it so sorry